so the college board is actually it's a
120 years old
and it's a non-profit which a lot of
people don't know
it's got 6 000 members and they include
colleges and high schools but
mostly consumers know it because of the
s.a.t
college admissions test and they also
know it because of the advanced
placement test
but we couldn't find any business
stories about
the business of the college board and we
were very interested
in what made that business run
they say that their mission is to
connect students
to college success and opportunity
and so i had a real question about
whether
they were really doing that i was
wondering what about all those students
that
can't afford to prep are they being
connected
with success and opportunity the college
board which is the owner of the sat
is a a billion dollar monopoly
b not connecting students to success and
opportunity
c facing an existential crisis
or d all of the above when cobit 19 hit
all of a sudden uh you know there was a
huge outcry because
kids were not being able they couldn't
take the s.a.t and
all of a sudden the college board
couldn't really
function what surprised us was that this
this wealthy monopoly was inept
at actually managing its way through
this crisis during our investigation we
just
we kind of discovered how
genius the actual business of the
college board was
which made it all the more puzzling why
it couldn't manage its way through this
crisis so basically today there's no
student who goes to college
that doesn't touch on a college board
product it was established by
about 12 schools and colleges i think it
was about nine colleges and two high
schools
in theory to administer increased access
to higher education
in theory since then it has spiraled out
of control we've looked at their tax
filings and we know that they make
a lot of money um especially for a
non-profit that they have
a billion dollars in revenue according
to their 2018
tax filing we know that they have a big
surplus
um which which they don't pay taxes on
and we also know that the
their executives are very highly
compensated so
their chief executive david coleman in
made almost 2 million so that's that was
interesting for forbes because we
were interested in in successful
businesses that
you know have big numbers the sat
in and of itself um isn't the most
profitable product
um the college board has they make a ton
of money on the fees that they charge
students
to do things like send scores to
colleges if a student wants to
send his or her scores to different
colleges it's 12
a pop if you want to find out what
questions you got wrong
it's another 18 to get that um if you
want to
rush your scores to colleges there's an
extra fee for that
so while the sat in and of itself which
costs
around 60 uh isn't that profitable
because it's
an expensive test they make all their
monies
and fees extra fees and it's not unlike
the way spirit airlines actually
makes extra money they charge a low
price to get in but once you're
on board there's extra charges for leg
room and
baggage and different things so it's
very much
in that model nobody knows what the test
measures
the least talented affluent kids
do better than the most talented kids
who don't come from affluent backgrounds
and that is profoundly an american
it's a social metric because it the fact
that it predicts
race and class uh differences so
powerfully equally as powerfully as it
predicts academic performance
um is is very telling i mean it is
uh it is systemic now and that's the
problem
i mean it's been known for a very long
time almost since the inception of the
sat
that performance varies
by by wealth by race
by gender by family income right
the difference between the lowest family
income students and the highest is
probably around 300 points
um and that that holds true sort of
across the different demographics
and part of that is access
to preparation access to information
resources in the school how much the
school focuses on
what the sat does or doesn't do well i
think
the system and and to a certain extent
the college board right may not be
responsible for the system but they're
absolutely propping it up and and
exacerbating it i had a sense
from my own childhood that the s.a.t was
unfair the suburbs of san francisco for
some reason had an s.a.t
prep class that i took and it really
improved my scores
um and i got into an ivy league school
because i had really good sat scores and
there was just that just seemed sort of
unfair
it is choosing a narrow
set of academic abilities
and it's testing it in a very specific
narrow high pressure environment
and pretending that it measures
more than it does i mean i do think that
that people at the college board
are largely well intentioned i talked to
several
uh highly placed former executives who
left very recently
and and so for rich people
um going to a fancy college doesn't help
them that much
but for a low-income student um it
it helps a lot in terms of changing
that the economic future of that student
and um
and so that's why i mean if anybody who
cares about
[Music]
decreasing wealth disparity or
increasing opportunities
for low-income americans
then we would want to find a way to help
disadvantaged students
gain admission to elite schools
and that doesn't seem to be happening
very much
you